now Raven was smart and he was not too
smart he was a mathematician
now mathematicians I've talked about
this idea for it I'm very very different
from say physicists okay now physicists
and engineers to an extent they'd say
look if you try to measure something
just get accurate and just get accurate
enough to do the job to build the bridge
to make the car go whatever okay like if
you can get you know a thousand
different places who cares like I only
need the first 20 for instance okay so a
physicist engineer might be happy with
this you can put it in maybe not die
maybe say 19 that be sufficient but a
mathematician is not satisfied with such
you know the adequate procedure they
want something to be exempt okay so how
would you turn something that's
approximate like this into something
that's exact right so instead of having
something really broad and not detailed
like this what you do is consider what
happens as n gets bigger right or if you
like what happens as the W gets smaller
okay and you can see it happening right
it's so funny you know me and my
reputation I could have done this on a
screen as you get more rectangles as the
rectangles get smaller at some point you
won't be able to tell the difference
between a bunch of rectangles and the
actual area that you're trying to get
which is from all its curves in now
question at what point did they become
indistinguishable
in the two rectangles of zero the answer
is almost we do want an infinite number
of rectangles okay but if there are zero
and I know what the yes right sure it
can't be zero
yeah just be really really close to zero
no this is interesting
okay what I want is an infinite number
of infinitesimally small rectangles now
think stop we've done this before
it was always rectangles those triangles
when do we have firing goals there what
infinitesimally small now keep in mind
I've ever been teaching you guys but you
know nine ten months so it's within the
time that I'd be teaching when did we
think about a triangle that was useful
to us but the triangle was big was not
useful to us yes yes yes you're a couple
of steps ahead Rosalie
it was when this squeeze lawyers
involved it was when a new trainer
workout gradients right we said look at
this curvy thing it's great it changing
all the time that's kind of frustrating
to me okay I can approximate it because
the grain will be close to rise oh sorry
that's wrong rise and run okay but what
I really want is a triangle that is you
know infinitesimally small and that
triangle in there okay now at this point
because it was no longer just a
conventional horizontal make it in a
conventional vertically we had to give
him special names do you remember what
we call
we call them we call rise dy right and
the D stood for what difference it's
good for change
right because Delta that's the like even
in science we use that to signify only
the to change we call this one the end
okay so just a little change in Y little
change in X so what I have here is the
same kind of scenario right so an
appropriate name should same afternoon
and after name for this little width
would be DX small horizontal that's all
gonna call okay so really said look this
thing here okay I can do Behrman
approximations I can say the area will
actually be equal to that if if I do
this business like makeup thing really
small okay so what I'll say is we said
we said it two different ways on writing
both ways I can say I want a whole bunch
of rectangles lots of lots lots of them
so I can take the limit as n approaches
infinity and it's how many rectangles we
chose right how many of this secret
okay or I can say Chris remember as the
width goes to zero okay no input um it
doesn't get it never gets there it can't
because otherwise the area will be zero
right but it has to get really really
close so it's the same idea because one
implies the other okay now he was like
look I've got a problem here right
because this Sigma notation right it's
really about adding up integer things
and I'm not talking about integers
anymore really okay so he did a new way
to talk about this big long song of it's
incident stole right but this C notation
here nowhere to be taken right so he
said hmm there are only other language
that he was having to write him was you
know just javascript is the same assumed
in English right except with more you
know that's so simple I still want a Sun
still in a song so I couldn't use a
letter S for some but everybody people
use s for what's su support displacement
I think right or deuces so he's like
that's out sure I'll just make it a long
yes okay it's still the same idea but
it's a sub of this is same thing now it
changes a little bit okay um this this
party off has all of that built into it
okay now he wants it to add up the same
kinds of things right so he's going to
have not just f of X K right because the
case starts to become this meaningful
because you just got a different number
of them so who cares what number of yous
I just like all right so we just said
look it's it's the function okay and
that's the that's a height that I'm
talking that as the height changes as I
know I'll move along the function okay
and then the highest e multiplied by the
width and we already decide what to call
the width right because that's what we
already decided from the differentiation
right so he said look height weight
that's what area is that make sense so
you see how the biggest comes from the
definition well he wouldn't write this
song for the first time he said I'm
gonna different one to n because similar
tation requires like where you started
from where you're gonna end okay
you can't that mean it's kind of meeting
this the same an entire area because
that would just be so he said look where
you stopped where you going to finish
he'd abandoned the idea of having it
having a K in he which was his count on
here one two three four five six
I was really useful to nummies well you
just start somewhere and you end
somewhere wherever you want soon okay so
he'd say well let's call that a and call
that B okay so instead of saying 1 to N
which is adding up in sequence okay say
well look let's different A to B right
and this is just wherever you stop he
called it your lower bound right this is
where we end so this is what he
described now he didn't know what was
equal to okay he said um this is what it
must be it's built off this idea okay
but it's different because this is just
a County along and and these things are
there's an infinite number of infinitely
small things so it's categorically
different but you can see the continuity
right you can see that this C bar turns
into this is Yvonne get a test
this one is in turns that Anna P this is
still height that's okay and this is
still right no but of course this per
second and make sure the story
I had to write this out for myself no
Rieman right
he called this first thing this thing
here he called it a Riemann sum very
very egotistical on him okay it was the
first guy to trying to approach that
publicly this way but I said look this
is a sum of of a whole bunch of
different things but this I feel is
different this is exact it's no longer
just the approximate part okay and why
he's written the process of bringing
together all of these things is really
about taking one whole thing and
chopping it up like you know so it's
indivisible okay so you said look this
is you're not just taking a Sun anymore
what I'm doing is I'm really trying to
combine or another word for that is
integrate a whole bunch of little things
into a whole so he said I'm not gonna
call this a Riemann sum anymore he
called it the Riemann integration
well integration to process and this is
this is an object so he said look I'm
gonna call this my super right and the
process by which I get there is called
integration okay
he's the important thing you need to get
the problem he was trying to solve was
area right and he didn't know how is God
actually gonna pan out in terms of like
the mass of it okay now the problem for
us is that the mass of it is really nuts
okay it's called the fundamental theorem
of calculus okay I couldn't really eat
there takes much better if you go
Cambridge it's gonna proof of it okay
well what I want to try and do you for
you instead I'll develop our rigorous
thing we'll just purchase leap is I'm
going to try and want you to do the
intuition I think you know enough from
from this idea basically to be able to
understand okay
have to do area have to do with gradient
which is something we that's where we
got safety for okay